we are ficus and ferns and this is best
dress sense today we're going to be
performing emergency fashion surgery
I've something a favorite entertainers
from cluster past
Hannibal Buress this outfit is lacking
definition let's raise the hemline and
roll the please we want to see more of
the man underneath the man if it's going
for a theme I to go for broke panel
patent shoes knee-high socks
there's nothing that screams confidence
more like your face on every inch of
fabric Wahlburgers I love his natural
main but I love to see more above the
ways perhaps added dark orange Fez for
contrast lacking in jewelry as well
aren't we
I'd add a stunning centerpiece something
that says I didn't study history but I
wear there it's Aladdin meets Egypt
yeah I love it I'm a Rachel bloom
schoolboy business none but why not pop
the whites with a sheer kimono I keep
the color and plunge the neckline to
pump up the sex appeal but also say
don't talk to me you'll mess up my GPA
has got loss average the key is to be
unapologetically you unless you're
wearing something to be sorry about
dress well and see you at class the
first